[تصفيق]
اخرجه الحدث دونالد ترامب يظهر من جديد
دون ان يملا الصوره وحده فلم يعد الرئيس
الذي كان وانما هو الطامح للعوده الى
الرئاسه من بوابه نصر ينشده في انتخابات
الكونغرس المصريه
في جهود حزبه الانتخابيه
مرشحا جمهوريا لا يبدو مستعدا لتلقي اللون
على هزيمه اي منهم
سيعود الفضل كله لي واذا هزموا فلا ينبغي
لهم على الاطلاق لكن عاده ما يحدث العكس
انا مستعد
انفسنا الدفاع هنا عن خياراته ورهاناته
لخوض معارك انتخابيه بدت لكثيريين معاركه
الخاصه
في كثير منها لم يتحقق النصر الذي تمناه
المفضلين والمؤيد كثير منهم كما يعتقد
لاجنده حركه
مقعدا حاسما للسيطره على مجلس الشيوخ بفوز
جون فترمان الذي يتعافى من جلطه الدماغيه
في ولايه بنسلفانيا ذات الاهميه
الانتخابيه الكبرى
كان فوزا على حساب المرشح الذي اختاره
دونالد ترامب بعنايه الدكتور محمد في
واحده من اكثر المعارك تنافسيه في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه
وجه الجمهوريه المقرب جدا من دونالد ترامب
هزيمه كبرى امام الديمقراطي جورج
[تصفيق]
من نصيب منافسه المحتمل على ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري لرئاسيه 2024
لن يجد ترامب في فوز الرجل ما يستدعي
لاحتفال اما نتائج بقيه من دعم ترشحهم فلا
يبدو انها تخدم خطته لخوض السباق الرئاسي
المقبل
المصريه نقطه ارتكاز لاطلاق حملته بعد
ايام
المقربون منه ما زالوا يعتقدون بقدرته على
تدشير كل حظ عاثر لمصلحته